foreign
how many years
to the final talk today it's by
Alexander Madre from epfl and he'll be
here on and off I guess over the
semester to answer questions
and uh and you'll talk on electric flows
optimization and a new approach to
macular problem yeah thanks Gary for the
introduction and thanks for inviting me
here it's really a very pleasant
Workshop I you know not a lot of Steel
about the area so yeah the title of my
talk is pretty lengthy but it is for a
reason because sort of the goal of this
series of these three lectures is to tie
together a bunch of different concepts
so essentially the idea would be to tie
most of the things that we have heard
about in the previous stocks and most
prominently the electrical flows and the
doors of the different flows with some
Core Concepts in optimization and sort
of apply this to for this to a set of
tools to a particular problem in graph
algorithms same with the maximum flow
problem but you know even though there
is the maximum problem in title you
shouldn't take it too literally like
this is just meant as an example of a
broader lead that I think is a play Hero
just like trying to get new tools for
graph articles okay so we'll focus on
vaccine flow but you know it's not only
about maximum okay so the point of start
here is you know one way of viewing
expected graph Theory or at least this
classical spectacular graph theory that
I guess Luca so the well talk mostly
about is namely we are trying to we are
trying to do here we are trying to
understand our graph is committed as
structure by a studying eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
matrices most prominently of course the
latashian Matrix okay so for this is you
know this is a great success story that
had many many successes and again Lucas
talk highlighted some of them but I
would argue that you know we are slowly
getting Asda and so after that is sort
of the next generation of spectrograph
theory appearing I would call it linear
algebraic graph here even though
probably there's a better name I don't
know what it is and somehow what we are
trying to do here is just we try to not
only look at eigen values or
eigenvectors they're just trying to use
some linear algebraic objects to
understand graph better and manipulating
better okay and somehow the central
object I would here is nostrophological
flows in particular the fact that that's
what John talks about is that we can
compute the craft flows extremely fast
okay sort of the goal of this lecture is
just to try to show to you how you can
incorporate this primitive or affiliator
flows into you know into something that
can be used in algorithmic theory at
large so as an efficient tool for
solving graph problems okay so those
linear algebraic objects they are almost
I mean they're coming from the spectral
basis yes I knew that someone would ask
that and I was the secretary yes that's
true
that's true but you know like the point
is that most of the times when we talk
about custom photograph Theory we look
at one eigenvalue maybe you know first
scale again values for small value of K
here we really want to look at the whole
spectrum and the nice thing about flow
is that it sort of gets access to this
whole wealth of information in one shot
right for the sake of the program and
it's titled maybe you can just enlarge
the umbrella instead of creating a new
one that's an interesting debate that we
can to have offline and actually we're
talking with an instrument about that
and I think he's with me on that you
know
so it is approved by Authority I guess
so you know it's a good thing and I'm
not sure what is the uh what is the the
right what is the right what is the
right name here but I just want to
highlight that there is some qualitative
difference here that we are just using a
different type of objects we will access
them in different ways okay
so
this is the plan and especially as I
said already our Focus will be the
maximum flow problem I actually there
will be smaller maybe not for small
interloop today about yet another
problem named random creation and this
is mostly for diversity I just wanted to
show this DM showing up in more than one
scenario and run those financial
generation is like what's happening very
simply not what I can actually
exquisitely into the lecture and you
know and say something about that okay
so this will be our focus and again it's
not about the examples it's about the
theme that is that shows up here and
maybe that the line beam here is that we
are trying to mesh computer and
continuous methods okay so roughly
speaking sort of very high level role
here is something that also don't
already mentioned mentioned in this talk
is that now we want to look at this body
of work on graph algorithms in the sort
of very communatorial in nature so we
talk about trees as partition and so on
and then we want to tie these objects to
some real algebraic tools yes like eigen
values algebra Flows In Your systems and
then what you want to do is we want to
use economics optimization Primitives as
an intermediary that allows us to turn
this understanding and its connection
into actual fast output okay so the
solution will be the underlying demand
again this is a part of a broader agenda
that I'm just talking about okay this is
really I think there is something
something foreign
okay so this is just this is just the
high level overview and maybe it'll just
start to be a bit more concrete so let's
just start by actually defining what the
maximum flow problem is so in this
problem we are given a directive graph G
with interior capacities on arcs and you
have two special vertices Source s and C
okay and essentially you know if you
find the A6 it might be easier you can
think of arcs as row so this is a road
network capacity is correspond to number
of lanes and smt are the original
digital destination okay and the roughly
the question is to well is to find a
feasible SD flow of Maximum value which
in this analogy translates to we want to
estimate the maximum rate of rate of
traffic from sop that this road Network
can can sustain okay so roughly speaking
uh what is a feasible SD flow so
visibility flow is an assignment of
numbers to access advanced two types of
constraints okay so one the one one
technical change of the flow
conservation constraints what they just
tell us is that there is no risk and
vertices under SMP okay so whatever is
the traffic is coming in it should come
out that's a very healthy constraint and
you know the other type of constraint is
the capacity constraint what it just
says is that you know there's no other
flowing arcs meaning we can't assign the
more flow to the tennis capacitor okay
so any assignment of numbers to arcs
that satisfies this
satisfies this this
flow and now what we want to maximize is
we want to maximize the value which is
just the net flow or out of s which by
flow costs division constraints is equal
to the net flow into into okay so here
on this example we have a flow of value
seven
but the actual maximum maximum value of
this graph is 10 and now here's an
example of a throw that's just atheists
okay
so this is the problem is the usual
question is why this is an interesting
sport to study okay why do we calculate
and you know the blanket answer is that
this is a fundamental optimization
problem and again there are some good
reasons to to well call it such so it's
actually so one reason for one reason
for for the fact that fundamental is
just you know the approved by induction
so it was studied you know in started
study started to be studied in 1930s and
since then there were many papers on
this so clearly it has to be important
because there will not be no notice
paper about that but also you know the
reason why it was started to be studied
so early on is that it actually has a
surprising diverse area of applications
okay so of course just for the
explanation I just gave you it's clear
what are the applications of
Transportation but the real power and
and the reason why it's probably so
interesting is that there are
non-trivial connection to many other
areas where this problem turns out to be
the core optimization primitive that has
to be solved okay
so this is one reason to talk about this
problem but the reason why I care about
this problem is that actually from the
first couple point of view this was a
very influential problem in development
of graph algorithms in particular but
algorithms in general so there are many
very very fundamental techniques that
were first developed to tackle this
problem later or people realize that
this is emotional can be a private role
okay so sort of the micro problem if you
look at the history of this world
because very like it's great hour of
sort of initiating this kind of new
techniques and new approaches okay so
that's why I like
okay so what is known about Max flow so
as you can imagine given the history of
the problem there is a lot of previous
work and I will not even try
to go over over it then he said home
book verythiquebook that adjusts that
just essentially contains results on a
maximum problem
and what I just want to do I just want
to do a very rough history out thanks to
philosophy what was happening
analysis of algorithms here is are the
works of Dynasty and the Ford Focus on
that essentially gave the first
algorithms for this problem the one
issue this algorithm is that there is a
dependence on U which is the maximum
capacity of the graph and you know since
they defend linearly on you they're not
really polynomial in our understanding
of the sense because we just need login
or log new bits to specify a
capacity of size 0 so these are not they
are not available
who actually showed the first polynomial
algorithm okay so they actually showed
that you can install discover an
employment time in fact it's even better
than that because they are strongly
polynomials so they in particularly
don't depend on the capacities of the
group okay
and you know later on there was a sort
of
just a technical actually if you're
counting here arithmetic operations in
all of these yes I'm cutting actually
kind of content operations of course
okay so
so later on there was some improvement
in running time again the log the
definition you came back again but now
it's in acceptable form it's a celebrity
on you and essentially you know by the
year I guess 85 so by the way you know
if there is always there are always two
discoverers for each of the bound and
the reason for that is that it was
during the Cold War so so one half of
the discoveries are from Russia the
other one is from from the US I guess
mainly and then I say that they always
find it amazing you know how they
managed to somehow always Discovery at
the same time similar Concepts I always
find it through the internet because it
shows that there is something something
beautiful and really like fundamentally
hidden
sorry this is called Titleist
okay so essentially by the by the year
85 85 you know the sort of the the best
running time knows of of a man and
to many people I think they were
believing that this might be the right
answer because you know this elephant
hit something called flow decomposition
bound and I will not explain to you what
it is
there are some heuristic reason why you
might try to argue that this isn't the
right amount but then there was a
breakthrough by Goldberg which lost a
gene here that's sorry
which essentially gave a running time
which is the minimum of the two times
and this minimum of the m to the three
halves and N times n two thirds and you
know the point one of the important
implications of that is that actually
you know this breaks this MN Bible and
this was quite a surprise okay and okay
so this is well this is roughly where
the thing stands but you know what I
want to do in this talk I want to
actually focus on a particular version
of the maximum profession I mean I want
to focus on the regime when we have when
we deal with sparse graphs so we assume
the number of arcs it's not much larger
the number of vertices and also I will
assume that the capacities are one okay
so one reason why I might want to do
this is that this just will make our
whole discussion a bit more focused but
actually there's even more than that so
in a sense if you look again at the
history of the problem then this regime
of spiral string capacity graphs was
always the one in which we had first
Improvement on the problem okay and only
later on when we have Improvement in
this
industry the development for modular
settings go okay so somehow this seems
if we this seems to be really The
Benchmark of how well and we understand
the problem
and also even in this restricted setting
this maximum problem already captured
some interesting problems in particular
Buffet matching but since
already is captured in this version okay
so this is this is the regime we will
work with and once we apply this kind of
filter to the previous result we will
see that essentially the work of
Goldberg
and you know essentially you know the
barrier is that like this is the best
that we know essentially and you know
you can view it as a sort of some kind
of value like this is a barrier which is
even more striking because the bound of
N2 u3 halves for the case of sparse even
capacity graphs was already achieved I
guess at this point it would be 40 years
ago okay that my work of event
so essentially we knew the for Mr
Secrets I think we knew this activity
has algorithm for a long time
but you know the only thing that happens
in the last 40 years is just you know we
managed to we managed to match this band
for increasingly modular settings but in
no improvement on this you know on this
on the stuff okay this was the well this
was the best we could do
and clearly you know if you think about
it you know this is not definitely like
we are stuck here not for lack of trying
there is some fundamental limitations of
our technique that we couldn't that we
couldn't overcome and essentially you
know what I want to tell you during the
course of this two lectures is a new
approach to the problem that actually
finally breaks
okay and again
now the point is not that we will be
breaking the spout the point is that we
will introduce a new approach and
somehow breaking this bound is just a
certificate that this is something
general that genuinely knew that we have
not seen before thanks for the right
time M10 so there is a kind of concrete
barrier which is the flow decomposition
for Android 1.5 there is also some
is a bit more technical like it's not as
concrete but it roughly actually goes
back to the ball growing argument like
essentially one way of thinking okay so
one of my feet is that the border with
argument is tight and the other thing is
just you know you just want to yeah like
okay let's give you just said that I'm
happy to go go over your friend but
there is yes there is a very concrete
argument that shows up in all the work
and it gives you N2 and three halves and
somehow we couldn't get it better for
this first class
okay
another problem
and the flow right yes but this is also
Builder it's like if you have something
in this size any sort of end then
there's a chance to be a good class
right
okay
so this is this is sort of our goal and
let's just let us talk a little bit
about you know how this this barrier was
was broken and somehow the point of
start here is that usually when you
approach some some buyer you know how
would you go about it well think about
maybe an easier problem and try to make
some progress there okay so the easier
problem here is just this the setting in
which we have an undirected graph and
actually we
even don't care about solving the
problem exactly we even don't care about
swimming approximately we just want you
to be able to approximately tell us what
is the right value of law okay so we
don't even ask you to provide us the
flow just tell us you know what is the
answer what is the value of the max flow
you're in the given well and even for
this setting this end to the Treehouse
barrier is what it was holding and the
question is now can you do something
here and well indeed as soon as as a
first indication there was a technique
that I actually allowed you to get
approximation to the value of Max flow
is not to it's not too hot like this is
not something really that the
Breakthrough but at least you know there
is some small
there is some small small hole input
which you can try to like pursue and get
something something more and indeed a
bit later this is the this is the result
drawing with install Cristiano John
canner and and that's key managing I
think it showed that actually when you
care about the proper approximations
that's where you carry about one length
of time approximation in undirected
graphs then something can be done and
you can actually get and Enter The
Fortress algorithm okay so again the
numbers important it's important that
this smaller latent military comes and
actually in a very beautiful and
stunning line of work this you know
especially these two algorithms and the
ideas behind them plus plus some other
brilliant ideas led to the best that you
can hope for in this regime that you can
get a one reception approximation to
maximum digital graph in close to linear
time okay so in this sort of setting of
undirected approximate we are done and
actually we we are performing better
than expected and everything essential
interaction okay so that's great but of
course you know that's only the under
under approximate the setting so you
know so after all the directed case well
it turns out that actually something
better can be done here it is only like
so as I said we are working here only
new capacity regime so this all this
results
although everything here generalizes
immediately to non-line universities but
this doesn't okay this is really a
result only for your conversation okay
and somehow my plan my plan for this
well for this lectures is that you know
I will talk about other things for the
well I will just give you a flavor of
what are the techniques Behind These two
results of that matter but I will go a
bit more in depth into them in each of
the separate lectures and sort of the
reason why I'm covering this this result
as opposed to this result in here it's
not because this is my result but
actually because the tools that come
into play here they show up here again
and somehow this will be easier to see
what the where the motivation for these
things come
okay
so are there any questions at this point
good so let us let us talk about you
know how can we how can we solve us so
far faster and usually you know when we
when we well try to introduce a new
approach it's a good it's a good thing
to spend some time and look at different
support and see what's happening
okay so the previous approach is
probably all of you know is the at least
if you want to get asymptotically best
algorithms is so-called augmenting
Upstream which was developed all the way
back
in the in the 50s by Foreign okay so
what's happening there well the basic
idea is just we want to solve a stroke
by repeatedly finding St paths in the
original one word okay so what does it
really mean so in in the unit
capacitance case this framework becomes
extremely simple and essentially what we
are doing we understand the following
game in which you know in each direction
we want just to find some SD path it
doesn't have to be short to expect just
any SD card in the in our current graph
and now once we found the SD path we
indicate that we found it by just
flipping direction of all the additional
graph and taking this new graph as our
residual graph and now we have our dual
graph which is for submitted and we just
look for another SD path unit again and
you know and we just once we find the
path we flip the edges out of the spot
and somehow we can flip some of the
edges back that's 485 and essentially
what is not hard to see is that you know
if we play this game long enough in the
long enough meaning until there is no
more SD password you can find then
essentially just taking the flip edges
and sending the incentive unit flow over
them will give us the Maxwell okay
so
so this is you know this is the general
this is general idea and you can see can
see you know it has many advantages
first of all it's just beautiful and
simple okay
also it's purely comatorial everything
happens by augmenting the flow a little
bit absolutely nothing happens
and also it's gritty which so it's
something that we like it's like we like
read the approaches at least as long as
they work okay and this is definitely a
good idea approach okay but of course
there are some problems and one of the
key problems with that is that it's very
difficult to analyze this kind of
algorithms in particular it's quite easy
to see that this algorithmetical unit
capacity case gives give us an N squared
algorithm all you have to notice is that
finding each path takes roughly off and
time and the value of Max flow can be at
most n so you can you just need to find
that most an argument in fact so this
gives you N squared but to go beyond
that is actually much harder and you
know just the more sophisticated
implementation and most difficult
argument this is due again to even
touches gives you n to the three halves
okay but you really have to work
okay especially on the data center
for the data structure yes okay so you
know so this is this essentially the
state of the Art In The Stream look like
n23 house is the best that you can do
and you know it's really unclear
this barrier that I told you about is
exactly hidden in this argument here but
essentially all like all it just says is
if I have two vertices that are you know
the shortest distance is what is the
best cut that I can prove his existence
of in destruction so if the graphics of
an edges then you can show that at least
one of the cards has to have a size of
the wall square root of L but that's the
best you can do in the workspace and so
for this is the value when you get MP3
so this is the argument that you have to
go away
okay
so this is the previous approach and of
course now the question is you know how
can different hands make progress
including this approach so how how to go
about something different so how to go
and some of the idea is well I already
said it is just to bring here algebraic
techniques into different okay so what
we want to do is we want to probe the
global flow structure of the graph by
solving your systems and yeah the
obvious question here even though
probably they're not so striking and
also positive now once you have seen
John stop and other folks is you know
how to relate something as commentary as
the flow structure to something you know
as in algebraic circular system and more
importantly why would you all have to do
that right like why would this event is
a good thing to do and of course there
is a good answer to that and this could
answer it responds to the notion of
electrical feedback so this is the king
ocean that spans these two computer and
uh
okay
so let me take a moment to the final
data flows even though probably by this
time you already are sick of it but just
maybe some of you just came for this
lecture well probably I'm probably like
it's been probable but maybe it can
happen so that's for this one person in
the room let me just Define the Antica
flows again I will do it quickly so
again
what is nice about them is that they
show up in many scenarios so also
because of that they have many many
equivalent definitions so one of them
just says the what is our main intuition
is that if I have an undirected
and resistance is assigned to add two
edges and sources and City and notice
that here the graph is undirected even
though in Max flow I allow the graphic
detected here is undirected the well the
way I get electrical fluid is I treat I
treat uh addresses the resistance of
corresponding resistance and then I just
connect the battery to SNP and look at
the current that's accessing this
in this in the circuit okay whatever
so this is a purely physical definition
I think better definition more
mathematically amendable is the
definition just by that sort of also
don't know I mean what you just says is
that one way of viewing autological
it's just this this is the unique flow
of an st flow feasible as our SD flow of
prescribed value F that is induced by
potentials via also okay so essentially
the electrical flow is this unique
property that you know there exists
there exists potential that will that
will induce it by also and
yeah and that's already draw said one
way of thinking about finding electrical
flow is just to find the vertex
potentials that induces so whenever you
find the vertex quotations
has a deficit of FSS a surplus of F at T
and no leads anywhere else this will be
a thicker Flow by definition
you know this has been hand clear and
undirected technique so can you say at
this level why you would not be daunted
by that and say look this is not going
to go anywhere once we get to direct the
crops and so why should we listen well I
have such a point in my third lecture
yes
exactly yes no one will come to my third
lectures if I give all the puns by that
but sort of well okay so there are two
answers to that so one answer is very
specific to Maxwell question then what
you can show is that actually when you
like Maxwell has a very curious property
that you know solving exact Max flow in
the active graph can be not used to for
the exact feedback flow in a datagram so
it's really not about ground being
unrelated or directed it's really about
getting succession accuracy so that's
one answer the second answer is a little
bit and again this will show up in the
in the third talk is essentially yes you
know if you have a if you are trying to
solve a direct question then yes of
course the graph is directed and you
know and theoretical flows are not but
somehow what you probably will do you
will want to have some improvement steps
yes so you have some kind of solution
and you would like to improve it somehow
and yes and again you can throw more in
one direction of the other but locally
you know if you are considering slowly
enough step things are things are
underrated in both sides essentially you
have some regular capacities in One
Direction and they are from zero okay
you you ensure that there are no zero
and then somehow in this local
neighborhood you know it doesn't matter
which direction your improvements rubs
the around the floor it's still okay so
like Global interdirected problem but
locally it's a undirected color and
that's what you are using and actually
that's what will be happening in the
third lecture when you will be solving
is to have an improvement procedure that
of course maintains a directed flow but
whenever it makes Improvement it assumes
like it takes small enough neighborhood
than in this neighborhood you can see
this under
effects to answer and the other one is
but until until your paper you're the
only one who believed that it would work
right
you didn't work you didn't believe it
but I'm not sure I was the only one
oh that's it because since filming date
right yeah so like that's what I'm
saying I know that James was a big scary
you didn't State any relation between
you are and
slowly
because well we will discover what it
will be for now it's just just defining
an electrical flow for some parameters
of R and then we will see what it will
be called and again we will see it in
the second lecture so you see that's my
only way of securing that you will show
up to my account
your aim is to find the value of the
maximum flow not to not actually produce
the market oh no now I want to produce
even myself so I only I will both know
the value and I will produce the product
okay
so this is the second definition and now
the third definition is actually the one
that visually this is the way we should
think about the problem well in what we
are listening to the sculptures then we
it views electrical flow as a result of
server optimization problem okay so
essentially what what the
supplementation is is just we are trying
to look over the space of all flows of
value F in our graph and we try to
choose the one that minimizes the energy
which energy is just the sum over all
the edges the instance of the H times
flow of the H squared okay so it's
really like the right view the vertical
flows in the store these to see them as
you know Earth minimization over the
space of Roads okay and this is really
the key way to think about it
but again all these three definitions
are equivalent and it can be proven but
you know this is that this is the
facility that we really want to everyone
okay so and you know so now we know what
the liquor flows are but of course we
want to have fast algorithms so we know
how to compute electrical process and
well clearly if you if you if you wear
business lectures you know what you have
to do but all you have to do is solve in
your system and some even years
and you know once you know that then you
can just refer to the previous though by
John and you know that you can compute
electrical flow extremely fast
okay when I say compute it actually
doesn't fit exactly you completed it up
to a very high Precision but that will
be enough for all of our applications
okay essentially
so from now on we know that whenever we
include probability the flow we can just
do it in their time so it's as fast as
possible and now the question is you
know this is a clearly a huge hunger you
know like just think about it what else
can you compute in New York Times you
can do a little bit of s you can compute
shortest path you know you can find the
spanning tree even so like you know
spanning tree but here these are all
very simple procedure and suddenly here
you have something so much at least
seemingly so much more powerful at the
same price time so it's clearly there is
some Hardware here question is how to
employ it and not only for Maxwell but
for other products as well okay
okay so no let me just let me just show
you how you know once scenario English
you already can use electrical flow to
get something productive so we'll just
focus for now on our diets I think okay
and how can we how can we do this here
and essentially this is this is the work
that already mentioned with all the job
okay
so yeah if I told you here is and and
there is a graph with capacities or
actually what comes in B1 and I here is
an Epsilon and you know can you find me
in one myself some approximate Max flow
in this graph okay so what would you and
I tell you that I want you to use any
graphics what you want to do okay so
first notice that we talked lots of
generality essentially we can assume
that we know what is the optimal value
of flow okay so I'm saying without glass
interacting because it just apply some
binary search strategory and you just
can get the candidates so assume that we
know what is the value of the muscle
flow and now you know what will you do
to actually try to approximate it okay
so here is a very simplest example so
what you will do well you want to
computational flows so probably you have
to impose some resistances okay so how
about some other resources being one
okay now once I have a resistance is so
low
and I couldn't even put a little flow of
the value of stuff okay because that
that should be the right flow so my
computer and what I can tell about so
one nice things about this problem is
that this is actually a validity flow
meaning that it is satisfying through
conservation constraints and you know
even though here you get it for free
this is something extremely important
okay so dealing with you know with with
some problems with flow conservation
it's extremely hard and extremely
painful so the fact that we get it for
free is very important okay so this so
this so the focus energy constraints we
are getting for free unfortunately you
know the other type of constraints I
mean the the capacity constraints they
are they might be valid okay so
essentially for instance here we have an
edge that that flows 1.5 when it should
only flow at most one and because of
that this is not a maximum flow okay
it's actually quite far from it and by
just playing a bit with the graph you
can make this kind of overflows much
much bigger okay because essentially
what's happening is identical flow is is
sensitive to resistance of the network
we attack resistance of the paths while
princess Maxwell doesn't differentiate
between part so if you have I have two
parallel paths for Max flow they are all
the same for electrical flow it depends
you know what is the effective
resistance from this one okay when it
chooses how much to refer to work okay
and just using this discrepancy you can
fool yourself you can flow to be more
and more like overflow more and more
where muscle will do that okay
so that's not good but the question is
okay well maybe you can do something to
fix that and again the most simplistic
way to do this is how you don't just
increase your businesses on this whole
referring changes okay increasing the
resistances makes the electrical flow
make for a little thicker flow to be
less desirable to Route too much flow
and because clearly this will you know
will never Flow it will be now it will
be more extensive energy wise to Route
over detection okay so once we increase
this resources well what can we do we
can just repeat okay the the whole
competition again and hope that after
not too many iterations this thing
converges to something reasonable and we
will be happy with it
okay so this sounds very simplistic and
essentially you know like why on Earth
would it work well the funny thing is
that it actually does okay and this is
essentially the general outline how this
algorithm works of course there are some
caveats you know there are you have to
be careful how to instantiate some of
the some of the some of the things that
I just mentioned here and I will talk
about the Skillets and how to make it
actually work in the in the second
planet okay so for now you know that's
all I want to say about you know since
it's like a teaser again trying
everything I can to uh to make you come
to my second lecture and so are there
any questions about that
oh so in the remaining time uh what I
want us to do is actually I want to to
like about second topic that also fits
this Dean and somehow in a different way
so maximum is actually recommended a
problem for which we use a linear
algebraic techniques and electrical flow
and now if you want sort of to do the
other way around so essentially we look
at the duration of random function three
which you can argue that is somehow a
new algebraic notion and then show how
you can go to get Advanced algorithms
for this problem by blending in
subcommitter of the class okay
and our goal is just to Simply output
and uniformly random Spanish okay so
essentially if this is the TG is the set
of all the scientists of Gene okay so
you hear some examples
and what we want is that we want to
output and given one given expanding
three probability that is one over the
size of the number of auditories okay so
essentially over
I just want to to sample a uniformly
random object from the set of financial
trees okay and you know one thing to
know is that actually uh okay there
should not be this should be no minus
one here essentially the number of
scientific references for a complete
graph it can be as high as n to the N
minus 2. okay so it can be exponential
in that so this probabilities can be
extremely tiny okay so that's just
something to keep in mind so you have to
be very careful you know with like how
your element works because like these
numbers can really be really small so
just that will show up so like this
concentration would be important
okay so this is the problem so are there
any questions about the initial tutorial
okay so the obvious question could be
that some of you might be asking a
reason why why this is an interesting
interesting thing to doctors and there
are some answers so again one of them is
that this is really a fundamental
probabilistic object in graph Theory
okay it's the deciding dates back quite
a while to works of keyhoff and
essentially there is a whole book a very
beautiful book
by lions and feathers on essentially the
in large part is about that's probably
it's called probability on treating in
large part just deals with trees
but also it has actually something
something of this of twist has some some
applications
and more importantly again from the
point of view of me as a theorist it has
deep connections to electrical flows and
the graphs are stories and we will see
some other shortcut and you know just
some example about these Connections in
particular there is a very nice result
that shows that if you give me a graph
and you just just take a look of two
mini form hispanically in this graph
then what you will get will be of course
advise pass graph and actually it will
lower bound your Cuts up to a factor of
four problem okay so it's somehow taking
two Union of two random standing Fields
with high probability gives you a lower
bondage personifier so it just gives you
the like this sort of make sure that in
every car there is sufficiently many
edges okay so that's that's one
connection other connection is actually
I should say okay maybe that's good to
say that but you know this connection to
specification is actually much different
than that and already essentially
already nickel said that that well in
his in his stock he was from the
specification it will corresponded to
just something and just proportional
into effective distance and as it turned
out in a couple of slight effective
resistance it has a very it will have a
very complete connection to a Randomness
but that's exactly why this was actually
appear as well okay another also another
another way another scenario the machine
shows up it's essentially there is a way
there's approach to approximating the
asymmetric primary system problem that
well that is based on finding some
objects completing trees and the random
Spanish tree versus Point trees the way
we know like where the best construction
of these objects they are coming from so
far okay
and also one more one more application
is actually the reaction I think this is
really cool so essentially if you if
your kids are bored you can you know you
can entertain them by generating them
infinite infinite infinite number of
maze puzzles so you know what you can
just do you just look at the grid you
find it on the spanning tree and this is
where they call it their goal and you
know that between s and t there's always
a unique path but it's a random path and
then you can entertain them for weeks
well I don't think it might it will be
entertained but some problem okay
so so
which is
wow so they generate pay uh spanning
please yeah essentially the connectivity
and they let the connectivity
yes yes but it
as far as like they indeed use three
packing to to do that but I don't think
that we use Randomness from your trees
yes and cards and clothes yes yes so
there is a beautiful Connection in
general you can see you can certify
connectivity of the graph by packing
trees into it you can just show that if
you have k-connected data graph you can
park at least K over to end this
geometries into it and actually we work
with with directly graphs and your
periodical activity and you will be
backwards that's it then discussions
actually absolutely tightening if the
graph is negative Decay then you can
park okay arborist Associated
yeah but that's I didn't want to Splash
it too much so that's not about rubber
connection but it does a beautiful very
fundamental thing that actually genre
it's personalized and so on and so so
it's a very important example
okay so now once we know why we might
carry all the following the question is
you know how to generate it on this
planet tree okay so how to do that and
you know one way of doing this is
exactly already the distance from the
work of carehof and and the connection
that's called automatic secure which
roughly says that you know there is a
very complicated between effective
resistance and erodon tree namely if for
a given Edge I look at the probability
that this tree will be included in the
random coming tree and this probability
exactly the effective resistance of this
Edge integral okay so essentially the
factors that we are looking thinking
that is just assume that all there is no
one and essentially solventification is
we should remember from the print stock
is that we just Loop we just like for a
given Edge we induce a current of one or
one end we retain a current of one or
another and then we look at the energy
of the electrical flow that that is
induced
somehow it happens that this probability
is exactly definitive existence of the
of the of the of the crystals
okay so once we have this connection
there is a very easy algorithm that
allows us to allows us to to sample our
information so what we just do we just
order edges of the graph arbitrarily as
we start with TV initially entry and
then what we do what we do we just go
over this edges one by one and for each
Edge we complete effective resistance
okay and then we add this Edge to the to
our created tree probability given by
this with probability given by this
and then once we made this decision we
just update G by well Contracting the bi
if we decided to include it in the tree
and just removing it from the graph if
you decided to not include monitor okay
and we just keep doing that for all the
edges and then we all put the tree that
we concerned this way okay so it
shouldn't be too hard to see that you
know the three that we created actually
will be entering because this is thanks
to the contraction procedure so
essentially
but you know question is why this would
be why will it work well one thing one
thing like one important thing is that
essentially by just having this
operation with either contraction of
removing but essentially condition if
you are encoding a graph conditioning
conditioning of our choices essentially
what is happening is that the unit at
any point of time the choosing a uniform
uniformly uniform spanning tree in the
remaining graph
so what corresponds to just extending
our tree in a course in a conventional
ecosystem model okay so essentially once
you unveil all the conditional
probabilities here what you will end up
is that you know that each Edge in your
tree is is sampled is belongs to the
strip like exactly with the red
probability okay and that's essentially
how you how you shoulder this angle it
works and then the other question is you
know how long running time so what is
the right time of this algorithm and
clearly the bottleneck the onion Shield
I feel that we are doing here is just
Computing the effective resistance okay
you have to look in each step but we
already know or actually well I guess we
know but I can also tell that there's a
very nice linear algebraic expression
for this effect tells us that all you
have to do to populating resistance just
to to complete okay which responds to
solid Cloud muscle system the only
caveat here is that actually you know we
want this sampling to be exact so we
want to have an exact solution to our to
our personal system and remember that
this the solver that were discussed is
fast so we're going to discussed they
are actually only approximate uh but you
know so that's that's what you would
think but then uh Gene Pro actually he
made a very simple observation but
beautiful
button that actually allows you to argue
that it's okay if you just have a good
enough approximation and you don't have
to get this fixed exactly and still you
will end up sampling the address with
exactly the right property okay it's a
simple trick but you know I'm happy to
describe it offline I will not
describing the stock but necessarily the
resulting running time is that we have
you know we have sort of two options and
you know one of them is just take
emigrations and in each Direction use
Gap designation to solve our system
exactly or you know have any iteration
and then initiation use approximate
solver and
and the reason why I'm actually keeping
this option and to the Omega here even
though here it seems to be to be much
worse is that actually you can be much
smarter like if you allow yourself to
invert The Matrix okay so if you spend
this time to actually embed The Matrix
then then you can actually amortize the
work for copy existing resistance over
the all the edges and in the end you
just spend the running kind of it's just
you know proportional to the to the
tinier to invert Matrix okay so somehow
you can hide this nucleation here if you
are smart okay this is
okay so essentially from this inside
from the small text to theorem these are
the running times that we that you can
obtain how does this compare with purely
algorithmic or rooted for realistic
algorithms
next slide
so okay so so this is what we what we
can do and the question is now can you
do better than that and well indeed well
in this instruction we can and this is
this beautiful really beautiful insect
of travel and almost
and what this show is that you can
generate those on a tree using random
Box by taking random okay so what's
happening here is that you can get this
understanding but it is using the
following City algorithm when you start
a random walk at some vertex s and then
what you do is well you start this this
random hook it starts visiting
competitors in the graph and then
whenever you visit a new vertex scene
you just add to your 3T The Edge to this
is occurred
okay so enough is speaking the arguments
like that so let's say we start our
other local s and then here which is
this Matrix over here clearly this is
the first digit so we take the
corresponding edges in then you know we
have next first visit we take a
corresponding Edge and so on and so on
here we actually revisit the same vertex
again so we don't we don't have an edge
and then we again have this Edge and so
on and so on and we get we come up with
some tree okay and you know and this is
the algorithm until why does it work
okay it's actually not really magic but
the first time you see it especially
when it suits in the paper it's really
magical like there's just some formulas
that miraculously come to be the right
thing but of course there is like that
but again that's something that I'm
happy to to explain
essentially the proof that they're
called yes that's what I'm saying that
it's not surprised but you know when you
see that when you see the proof the way
they did it this is It's Magic because
also there is proof by you know this
couple from the past technique and it's
also this is beautiful and mathematic
only later you realize oh I was strict
like this is something to be expected
but it's just you know this is really
beautiful stuff okay so this is so so it
works actually very much okay but how
about the running time well clearly what
you have to do well you have to simulate
the work until it it means every vertex
in the graph so essentially in iranine I
was able to strap the you know the
proportion of the cover time on the
graph and in the worst case we know that
the cover time of a graph is MN okay so
this is actually the the right so it
improves the M squared part from the
previous slide it doesn't necessarily
does not necessarily improve the
antidote Omega part when the graph is
and actually Wilson he got a different
handle process that's sort of similar
framework that actually gives you this
random spelling chain of mean heating
time we don't explain what it is but
it's something that in some graph is
smaller than cover it's always abundant
by cover time but it's something smaller
than the cover type but see in the worst
case it's often
what about the most obvious thing I mean
think of of this from the maker
perspective you start with the three
whether a random Edge this creates a
cycle you throw away well that's exactly
sort of one way of getting this Android
right
and then you like and then essentially
so this is this is yes like this again
coming for the past like essentially
look at this process where you you run
it in the the other like against the
time and then you just realize that yeah
after after a long enough time you were
able to reconstruct what was you know
what is the uniform you understand just
by observing information now that's
exactly the idea
okay
good so you know so we we have this off
and then one said the question is you
know can we can we improve upon that
well and you know so one instruction
thing to do here is just to look at the
back case okay so when does this
algorithm standalone-based algorithms
perform badly and probably all of you
know what what are the bad cases for
that is something called like
graph which whose cover time so we have
a complete graph on like coming off and
matrices and then we have something like
the path of length over and over as well
and what is known is in the cover time
of this graph is cubic right this is
of course if you start over here
so that's an important thing yes
yes
exactly like let's define cover time as
over like the worst case
it's much easier if you start from here
okay so you know so photography what
happens is that essentially When You
observe this like once the swap starts
here what will happen is that it will
quite quickly cover the whole the whole
company yeah but then it will take many
attempts before it manages to push all
the way through to the to the last to
the last part of the office okay so this
is where this end Cube cover time is
coming from vacuum so this is the sort
of the bad news but then when you look
at it you know you observe something so
you know one thing that we know from
that is that you know from the point of
view of our algorithm all we really need
to know for every vertex is just the
first
and since we covered the Caden graph
very fast we will get this first first
these edges for all the businesses in in
the game relatively fast okay so stuff
we already know how our random tree will
look in this graph somehow then we have
to pay a lot of time well just to make
sure that we also figure out how it
looks in this path light so it's an
essential just a path it's just a path
like that how it looks there
so let's make an observation you realize
you might come up with a foreign idea
okay so how about just doing the
following how about just like cutting
this graph into halves at least half
okay or I'll just actually cut it even
more and just like essentially you
identify these pieces that have good
cover type you know and there are not
too many of them hopefully and then
yeah and then you know you just find you
just simulate the random work in each of
these knowledge of these pieces you know
you will get ideally you would like to
get some trees and then you spice these
trees and then you get you know and then
you get the random strings definitely is
fast because you don't have to like once
you cover something you don't have to
like spend a lot of time there to to
just push out to other parts of the
cloud okay so this is the idea actually
this is a good idea even though it
doesn't work you know the way you would
like to to apply it more simplistically
because the problem is that somehow okay
so over there there was a cut with just
one Edge which is simple but in general
I'll discuss might be small but not a
lot of Financial and then if you look at
sort of the intersection of a given part
of the graph with granular spiral tree
it might not always be a tree okay it
actually might be some forest and then
once you try to splice this random for
us to make sure that they form a randoms
like a tree in the first place and the
random spawning tree
well in general this becomes very ugly
and it doesn't really work okay so you
know so maybe the most simplistic idea
doesn't work here but we are on to
something here and actually there is a
way of turning this activation into a
general approve so roughly so what you
do you indeed catch your graph and you
said lucky cut you you just use
initially ball growing technique of
latent route and described to cut your
graph into pieces that have low diameter
each and have small interface so the
number of edges between different pieces
and smoke
okay and that's what you do well you
again run the random walk in this whole
graph but do you do it in a smart way
okay so the smart way what it
corresponds to is that there is a
certain shortcutting certain
optimization in this so maybe if in one
of this piece you know my work already
discovered all differences and edges so
I know already how my tree looks like
then you know whenever I am about to
revisit the same piece again in marital
book I actually don't do it what I do
instead is a shortcut so essentially if
I'm entering this cluster at some vertex
C instead of simulating this random walk
inside it should be very wasteful what I
just do I just immediately wants to just
choose one of the like one of the edges
through which I will exit According to
some appropriate circuit distribution
and just you know and just immediately
go there and continue wherever okay so
essentially I don't want to spend time
on realistic pieces that I already fully
explored okay
so essentially so essentially this is
the idea and notice that once doing that
like by strokating different amount we
are not using any information that we
really need because we still retain all
the first first so essentially we are
just cutting out some waste
contradictory that would make us learn
anything about the tree and essentially
since we have like each of these fields
is so diameter then it's covered
relatively relatively relatively quickly
and since we have small interface then
the number of steps over well between
different pieces is also not too big as
well okay so this is the basic idea but
of course there is a basic element so
one thing that that we don't know how
yet is just how to exactly do this for
something we're going to enter the
immedi X by one of the edges with
appropriate probability problem but how
to compute this probability so we're
roughly speaking you know what it is
that we want to do so imagine this is
our cluster and this is the rest of the
graph and what we really want to do we
want to be able to complete the
probability
PV of you know if I enter a Vertex V
close cluster what is the probability
that among all the possible edges I will
through which I would I could exit
through I will exit through this
particular entity okay
so well an ideas how to compute it
yes great yes the the funny thing is
that you can just use electrical flow
for like as a solver to answer this
question so essentially there is a
there's a theorem that okay what
specifically the setting what it says
essentially so what we do here is just
we take this outcoming address and we
just keep them one of them goes to one
vertex you start and the one that we
want to actually that we're interested
in goes to the to the to the original
protects you and now it adjusts to two
vertices and all you really need to know
is that if I start a random moment V
then a real life has first hit you or
you will like first hit you start okay
this is exactly corresponds to copying
this probability but now this kind of
you know will I hit here first or here
first probabilities you can use
electrical from school to compute them
namely the theorem roughly says is that
all I have to do is I have to impose a
voltage of zero at your start voltage of
one at a deal and then whatever voltages
will settle on the rest of the vertices
they will be exact actually equal for
these probabilities okay
so we can clearly like check it that
your Hue is one so well that's the right
thing because I mean you immediately are
in you as opposed to fitting if you
started to start at zero and then
actually the beauty of of the connection
between electrical flow and networks is
that you can prove that you know for
every vectors whatever the voltage will
be will be exactly the probability that
our random works at the V will hit you
before hitting to start with responses
I have to do that so that's part of the
running time analysis and
you know and again the problem is that
in principle I you know I need this
competition to be exact but actually
this there's a depression by a problem
so that that's really good sufficiently
good approximation suffices and you know
once you put it all together which I
will not do but yes this will include
Computing you know how many times you
have to compute it for different edges
what you will get is you will get a m
test scores of an algorithm
[Music]
okay so this is so this is the bound and
you know this is again for startup this
is n2a3 house and again it's actually
for the same reasons that other MP3 have
so again what is happening inside there
there is some more growing argument that
is tight and gives you so the question
you know can you actually break this
activity has very appearance indeed the
UK this is a this is a recent work in my
under students I guess that's that's how
you say it and roughly speaking just
this is just what was like so what is
the idea here so first of all you know
it's always when you want to break some
barrier it's good to look at some tough
examples for the previous algorithm and
the tough example from the previous
Albert is the following graph in which
we have two expanders okay that are
joined by roughly square root of and
Paths of square root of and like each
so the reason why this is a tough
example for our previous algorithm is
that this graph has you know antibiotic
has cover time so if I just want to
simulate the work as it is it will be
taking advantage rehab simulation mode
but unfortunately there is no good way
of cutting it into smaller pieces it's
like we can't really like we should try
to apply the ball growing it will not
give us anything interesting it will
exactly hit the streets that leads us
into electric house so roughly there is
not it's not too hard to know what to do
with this kind of
okay and here are like especially our
our new algorithm is just based on just
three sets that I think are more
important the algorithm itself so one
thing that you know like there are three
elements that we need to overcome this
kind of problems so one thing that is I
think most important is that actually in
this well to overcome it you actually
have to look at the right metric for the
problem okay so instead of looking at
the graph distance metric so we are
looking at the low diameter low diameter
this is what you want to look is
actually we won't look at effective
resource metric that's induced by like
there's this embedding that nikhil was
talking about and you can embed your
vertices of the graph into into L2
according to squared actually and then
you know distance like the effectiveness
distance will be approximately below the
low dimensional and then the refractive
resistance distance distance between two
points is exactly you can just compute
by looking at the L2 Square normal okay
so instead of looking at the graph this
is metric in our partitionings we look
at the right metric here which is the
effective resistant and the funny thing
that happens then is that for instance
even though in the graph distance metric
this two expanders are far when you look
at the effective distance metric they're
actually very close to each other okay
so that's that's the surprising thing
and so in a sense even though you know
they don't look like this on this
picture they actually there's two graphs
together they form a region of low
effective resistance diameter okay which
is a a desirable thing for us and then
what you do well then actually once you
are able to identify big regions of
small effective distance radius then
what you do you just sample your tree
you sample your twin phases so
essentially whenever you identify such
region you discover what is the how look
like in this region then you're
conditioning appropriate way and your
occurs okay and just the last missing
piece is that you have to say okay if I
have like you have to say that if you
have two readers that are big and are
not close to each other in effectiveness
of metric then you have to you can do
something and indeed you can prove like
it's some analog of sugar technology you
can show that you have two regions that
are far away in Effectiveness metric
there has to be a good capital in there
so then you can do cutting and just sort
of apply the strategy from the from the
previous algorithm okay so sort of like
so for hard cases you can this new
Optics allows you to just to just create
history in stages and if this new Optics
does not help it means that actually
there is a better account than you can
find okay can you just use the fact that
a factories is L1 and valuable
I would need to think about it okay
so yeah like I have to discussion that's
interesting so I have to I have to pass
an exclusive and what does the graph
look like in the
in the television uh
it looks like something like
like something like that it's like these
paths are pretty far from these
expanders but these two expanders are
closed right this is like just thinking
like so take a distance corresponds
roughly to the to the commute time
between between this well it was
interesting points so the funny thing is
that all this stuff the facilitates like
there are long but there's many of them
so that so you can always like sort of
counter on one of them getting you from
one side to the other but you know the
part itself actually are pretty far from
when you insist that I want to go from
here to here then this actually will
take much longer time
so so it's still the whole graph has
effective resistance uh the metal being
Omega of square root of n but you know
this exponents are actually close it
doesn't I mean it doesn't make a lot of
sense because the commute time
I mean the human time gets better
because you add more engines but if you
look at the process of going you still
have to walk along a path okay yes but
you can return by a different buffers
right so
um
so okay so that's uh that's essentially
graphic so once you put all the math
together what you get is entered the
four thirds time okay it's still not
linear but when we are getting better
and yeah that's all I wanted to say but
let me just so does it work for
something K forests
no first if I've heard the customer I
don't think that anything works for us
because they have the same determinant
process right yes okay like at some
point I thought about this and I
realized that this is like like there
are similarities but some of the crucial
are missing I don't remember which one
are this we can talk offline maybe I'll
never report like I thought about it
because I tried to make it work but just
if you were able to indeed just you know
cut it into pieces and and splice
everything nicely you would get a very
fast algorithm yeah there are some you
know it was a couple of years ago but
there were problems like this products
are like forests are significantly
harder to tackle than diet trees
okay
so what happens is I thought I just
showed you two examples when electrical
flow ended up to be a key algorithmic
quality okay so I just I just made the
aggregating ball because the point is
that you know it's not as a electrical
flow like we know a lot about electrical
frocks the connection to the structure
of the graph but now we really use them
as an algorithmic tool it's we want to
compute something and then it has a lot
of videos you can flow is a mean to this
ad for us okay so that I think what is
important it will take away from this
talk and of course there is no this is
not the only examples when electrical
flows computation were very useful
algorithmic primitive and you know and
even more importantly I think this is
just the beginning there will be much
more of this kind of applications for
particular processor as a graphical
imperative and again I just want to
highlight that you know to make this
application successful we always had to
use this deem of merging continuous and
commentary perspective okay so for in in
random trees we have to find these
partitions because without them if we
couldn't make our algorithms fast enough
we have to use the power of solvers
which already play on this on this
connection quite a lot to be efficient
in each case it really was important
that you know we use tools for more
perspective and sort of and combine them
together to Better Faster algorithm if
you just stick to one side well we just
gotta get and we just don't get back so
I just want you to keep in mind and I
just a small remark is that in this
picture I put you know this is
commentary algorithms and then I put
this optimization we have not seen much
of it today but this we will see a lot
of it in the in the in their menu today
actually okay
and again as I said max flow is just an
example and you know the ultimate goal
behind it is actually just get a new
next generation of tools for their
algorithm in general but Maxwell is a
nice example but it's only one problem
and in particular nice thing of tools
that are that we get via this around is
that well first of all there are eight
people of making progress on things that
you couldn't make progress that's one
good thing about about these tools
another thing is that actually they
nature and so forth they close ties to
the optimization show that they are very
robustness and in particular you know
one nice thing about them is that often
they allow you to be you know depending
on what is your time budget they allow
you to get some decent answer but not
exact answer but it might be approximate
like you can train your approximation
versus running and this is something
very desirable for instance if you want
to do big graphs and so on where you
know you can't afford too much of time
so you want to do the best you can with
the resources you have
and that's
[Applause]
you can make sure that the random
straying tree should have the same kind
of time as undirected back and flow High
congestion that it should be New Year
which is the same like projection from
your phone because what I don't have to
conjecture that's cool yes I think that
it's again it's there is actually no
reason why it shouldn't be moving at a
time there are some stupid technical
reasons but they are just they seem to
be enough for them for you anyway
is that we will find the right you know
projection like essentially we have
enough of insights from commentary side
of the things to speed up the other
direction and I think at the same time
thank you so already now moving to this
like effective resistance based metric
like in a sense it a bit reminds me of
preponditioning and all this stuff so we
are sort of using partitions in the
rhythmatics now now we just have to get
better partitions and hopefully things
will understand
I really think that you know just we are
lacking on the Commodore understanding
of the of the everything
yes what do you think is the complexity
of computing a random operations in a
directive graph
yeah this might be hard I I think that
yeah I I have no good intuitions like I
thought a little bit about this and I
couldn't
come up with much like directs and
drafts like in that case there is really
like it's okay if Max frog when they say
directly we have single hour are the
same direction
think exactly in advertises like most of
these techniques is
not clear there what would be the
Commodore part because the partitions in
the in the Neptune that they don't look
nice so like I I think it's like N
squared though or something like this
right and then and I don't like I want
to hope that you can do better but I
don't have good reasons to believe what
you can do better like this is this is
the regime
now
thank you
foreign
[Music]